foreign
discussion rather than a complicated one
so we can finish in time
and mine is that I think that
human clones are fine we should have
human clones that there's nothing wrong
with human clones and that's right now
there's a kind of a taboo about making
human clones but they're perfectly fine
because we already have human clones
they're called twins
there's you know simultaneous
clones but we get all freaked out with
serial clones
and actually in fact if we had did not
have twins and we suddenly invented
twins
people would call them the devil they
would just say that's just insanely evil
if we had twins and that we didn't have
them naturally
so so I think that
it's perfectly fine just to have serial
twins rather than just simultaneous
twins
okay
but according to you Kevin we can eat
them right as long as exactly and we can
eat them too
twin farming eat yourself.com in saying
that
the reason people are like weirded out
by by serial twins is because of the
Insight it gives into the psychology of
the person who wants to serialize
themselves more so than the actual
cloning well you don't have to actually
serialize yourself you can make twins of
anything you don't have to make a twin
of yourself you don't have to clone
yourself you can't clone anything you
could clone your neighbors if you wanted
to it's Clon Einstein right exactly so
it's not just cloning of yourself that
you have to do okay so you clone your
kids so you have an air and a spare and
you just keep going yeah
and then they could marry someone who is
ill-suited so Kevin what would you like
to see happen then I mean you're making
an ethical statement that this is okay
instead of not okay right but what would
some use cases be you think there's
obviously many people who lose a child
or something who would like to restore
that
bring them back so to speak
and so
I don't think that we should prohibit
that just basis on the fact that there
are clones
but Kevin can I ask a question about
that I mean what's the at a deep level I
understand that people have that
instinct but what's the advantage of
that relative to a like a non-cloned
because the new clone like identical
twins won't actually be the same person
exactly they might look alike for some
period but there there won't be the same
person and so if you had let's say you
lost a child and chose to have another
child I think if someone said we lost
our child we decide to have another
child none of us would think what a
terrible ethical reaction we would think
oh that's very understandable we
wouldn't condemn it but that's because
they would be acknowledging that it
wasn't going to be the same person all
over again and even if they named it if
they named the child the same thing we
might raise our eyebrows quietly amongst
ourselves saying gosh don't they want
this child to have its own identity but
we probably would let that go too after
all we don't get too upset when people
name their kids after themselves sure
you know we know that they don't really
mean that that's going to be their kids
going to be a mini me yeah so I I don't
know I guess what I'm wondering is
what's the added value there I
understand people have the Instinct but
I
why is it any better than just saying
just have another child if you feel that
way I think you're right I think there's
gonna be a lot would be a lot of
self-correction that in a sense that
people would understand that clones are
very rarely possible to have an
identical thing and so there would be
less maybe demand for it but it'll be
another Choice another option and there
might be times when it worked out I just
don't think it should be a Prohibition
the reason why there's a Prohibition is
there's a fear that they're going to be
taking over that there are our lives
will be full of clones and that there'll
be nothing but clones and so where does
the prohibition come from
what if it turns into one of these like
weird Gattaca Elite things where you
start cloning people you think are
really smart or you know Usain Bolt or
something and you create this like
weird Elite Class you know I think what
they discovered was to Noah's point is
is that cloning is there's no guarantee
that you're going to get necessarily
what you think you're going to get
because of we know twins themselves they
vary between each other and triplets
likewise I think you see often how
something which is super well
intentioned can run afoul of what
actually is best for society so you take
the example of sperm donors and who are
trying to help families get pregnant or
single mothers conceive and then you end
up having these cases where there are
other doctors or individuals who
ultimately have 500 children out in the
world which is a deep deep disservice
obviously to those children because now
you need to get genetically tested when
you start dating someone to make sure
that you're not dating your half-sibling
and that seemed like a pretty
unappealing thought so the idea that we
would have a massive number of clones
out there all of them have to figure out
whether in fact they're huge genetic let
alone psychological issues associated
with it because as they get older
they're not going to be able to
self-identify as clones
doesn't that worry you what do you mean
well because even identical twins
relatively rapidly don't always look
alike and so you're not immediately
going to be able to know who's your
sibling who's not
whether you're intermarrying and doing
all sorts of things so from a genetic
perspective it doesn't seem like a
particularly wise thing for the species
to have thousands and thousands of
people who have their identical genetic
code right so you're saying if as soon
as you have clones you have thousands of
millions of them no you don't
necessarily but just the way no one
assumed when you had the opportunity to
have sperm donors that you were going to
have some idiot who decided that he
wanted to have 500 children right so I
would say you might want to regulate
clones but that's very different than
prohibiting them are they prohibited
right now yes I don't know if it's a
treaty but there's an agreement among
biologists that they're not going to do
human cloning okay okay yeah I mean I
think one of the reasons for that worry
is that the kind of worry that well both
of the worries both Josh's worry and
Maggie's worry that we're worried about
people you know trying to make tweaks to
the Clone and then tweak the Clone so
that they develop the germline in new
ways and that has both risks and ethical
side but I wanted to ask just taking on
your court case
I think the best thing you could say on
the opposite side you almost have to say
this is there's something about human
reproduction that should include
recombination and the randomness that
comes out of that recombination because
we're not saying it's completely random
because we let people choose who they're
going to have kids with if we're able we
want to let people choose and so we're
letting people decide within some
boundary who they're going to mix their
genetic material with but there is some
unavoidable inescapable and I think most
people think good Randomness about what
happens when you combine two genomes and
I guess that question would be what do
we lose if we give that up and I think
what we lose at some basic level is the
beauty of human variation
you know I mean and the thing about
twins is that that's also a product of
the randomness of human variation
especially identical twins well not
really ifvs is there's a huge
preponderance but those aren't identical
twins
almost always for example and I'm
talking about identical Choice yeah
exactly identical twins are themselves
it's a rare outlying random experience
so my argument would be that we
shouldn't as a society want to encourage
human reproduction
that it doesn't have that element of
Randomness because it encourages us to
believe that we can plan out in advance
what someone's going to look like and
from there
what their life is going to be like in
some way and it's already benefit I mean
I'm a parent of teenagers yeah I already
sorry I'll just close I'll shut up I
already have two I'm too invested
already in what my kids turn out like I
need to be every day I wake up and try
to be less invested in that and here it
just feels like an invitation to people
to be more invested well no just to your
point the societies that have tried this
most closely which are the royal
families of Europe is inevitably ended
badly the enormous Jaws huge health
issues because they were convinced yeah
they were convinced that the way to
ensure exactly what Noah described was
to intermarry and the result was
insanity and deep deep physical
deformity so any experiments that we've
seen in real life have not ended well
right to the extent that there are
problems that wouldn't work I think
those are going to be self-correcting
you would say okay
we don't want to do this or trying to
engineer this always have trade-offs and
whatever we could going to try to
eliminate this disease Parkinson's
Alzheimer's there is inevitably going to
be some trade-off If you eliminate that
kind of a gene from your clone and so
Eugenics we're drifting into Eugenics
and and that's the concern is that this
turns into a form of eugenics but it
doesn't have to
again I think we want to have the option
of it we don't want to close off the
option we want to be able to manage it
and do it just like you know we don't
prohibit twins would you allow people to
sell their genetic material so you see
some person who's super successful and
she decides you know what
if you want to have someone like me I've
been super successful
I'll sell you a clone of me and so
couples are deciding right that they go
off and want to have Maggie as their
daughter would you allow her to do that
that's a decision people do buy and sell
eggs right I mean for surrogate babies
and and I don't know if sperm is
actually sold or not you can sell it I'm
not sure you have to buy it